tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo nuovo
video sono fa vj
ebbene dalla partenza fantastica siamo
su un nuovo blog ragazze di tanto
ragazzi a los angeles la twenty century
fox che ha prodotti xmen giorni di un
futuro passato in occasione dell'uscita
del 2 ottobre in dvd e blu ray è stato
uno dei viaggi anzi forse è stato il
viaggio più bello della mia vita fino
adesso perché è sempre stato il mio
sogno quello di andare negli states
vedere di tutto i ragazzi vi lascio al
video perché sennò non facciamo più
ok ho fatto colazione ragazzi sono
appena sveglio c'è una roba che la
mattina non posso fare cose sono proprio
morto l'altro ancora una busta rosa sexy
che non mira a che cosa serve alice
fatti j
sto passando macchine tipo il grand
theft auto
no sto scherzando al nostro guidato io
no perché non ho ancora la patente dagli
altri prof mi sarebbe piaciuto farlo
sono le 11 sono aereo alle all'una più o
meno così come sono
bravo figlio che sta tranquilla in
macchina quando mio padre guidato
tranquillo però quando parte il prof
[Musica]
ok ragazzi siamo all'aeroporto ci siamo
mi devo imbarcare tra pochissimo
dall'altro devo capire una to do devo
andare in archivio che quest'inter in
ricordo malissimo perché c'è la
videocamera
quell'idea contenta
è probabile
erika ci sia sono esausto già solo
salito una scala fantastico è la prima
volta in assoluto la primissima che
prendo un aereo quindi sono una carica
pazzesca
c'è uno spazio è talmente ampio che mi
verrebbe da uscire nudo e corre in mezzo
agli aerei che non soffre giuste idee da
maniaco però sarebbe troppo figlio ci
hanno dato giusto un po di roba c'è
neanche tanto volete anche voi perché
tanto non so che cosa farmene
sbaglia tutti come
no perché verso e da tito speri di
questo
[Musica]
gazprom eni spa con pippo è cambridge
sta che ho trovati siamo nell'aeroporto
di londra
ho trovato la cioccolata mia la free gj
io questa è la prendo sopra il nome
bellissimi devo magnate però ci sono
schifezze quindi non so che cazzo prende
quindi portati adesso sto per salire
sull'aereo quello definitivo per los
angeles premi un attimo che secondo me
mi piglia ma che sono registrate non
fosse perché los ángeles restano adesso
sono nel cesso dell'aereo alla beta e
basta comunque niente sono qua acceso
perché penso sia l'unico posto in cui
posso registrare team pagani pigliamo
con un terrorista la tipa che c'era e
che sta di fianco a me ha provato a
parlargli inglese massimo che sollecita
dire è stato tipo hashish
cose così il mentecatto notizia che
stava guardi bianco cioè che sta a cantà
tanto decantata accesso ad esso
ha fatto transformer è un'attrice che ha
fatto trans centro tutti i posti della e
lo sconosciuto vicino a una grande patto
transformer prendeteci per sul gol
intanto ci sono strutturati in europa
il computer navigato con un movimento a
fare un gameplay
non uno di meno
non mi bombardano invece
[Musica]
ci crediate o no questo è l'hotel pulsa
di alcol sto posto tre quarti della
gente che c'è qui e tipo famosa quindi
probabilmente intera godzilla prima o
poi comunque sono ancora entrato è tanto
il rumore e la na figata quindi dal
rumore già abbastanza buono c'è una luce
da voi che questo niente regala stanza a
letto non alla luce però non si sa come
mai mi è andato due letti
forse pensavano che occupassi due posti
non lo so comunque non lo fa un culo
come cazzo si si doveva schiacciare
perfetto ragazzo non zheng sono un genio
in queste cose comunque cose
normalissime tipo tra l'altro ragazzi
nelle prese della corrente in america
sono sono troppo tristi
cosa cazzo c'e nell'armadio perché c'è
un [ __ ] asse da stiro
ok si aprì la porta la bula bula c'è la
polizia che mi hanno già trovato lega
viaggio a trovarci ha messo poco a non
mi ha visto non mi hanno visto meglio
così
che vivo
drop dead drop di hollywood ma nella
maglietta tutta la vita certo di no ma
mi sa che poi siamo arrivati proprio nel
punto ho conosciuto spider man il loro
operato è sceso da
a jackie e freddy krueger navale regalo
è una figata tra l'altro c'è anche
topolino ragazzi sto cercando tutti oggi
zaia sta facendo di preciso
è un grande abbiate pazienza però me ne
vado
[Musica]
o regalando un luccica estrema nostra
cosa a sting justin di portò via
i ragazzi lo portò via
[Musica]
ok ragazzi siamo solo all'hard rock cafè
di hollywood
abbiamo deciso di mangiare qua perché
dopo andiamo dove ce lo insegna
direi che possiamo andare a mangiare
ragazzi adesso dovrei andare a niente di
che si gira ma che cazzo dici da mi
sento critiche perché se non faccio i
blog così perché in seria questi
sarebbero i blog poveri e sono che mi
sento osservato vabbè comunque
non dovevate cioè tutte troppo gentili
però hanno voluto premiarmi con gli
occhi
[Musica]
grazie non dovevate comune è un ardino
deve serve qualcuno
ma hollywood land è fantastico no anche
chi chi gli skate così no basta non ne
voglio uno che mi ammazzo però lo voglio
me ne frega un cazzo chiericati ripresa
in mezzo alla strada che sono bellissimi
mi fa veramente troppo sottostante altre
stiamo andando verso dove
comunque io non pensavo che la volkoff
haim fosse così fottutamente grande cioè
enorme
ok cro da allora sono i boss
siamo sulla scritta di hollywood ragazza
e tipo lontana non si vede poco però è
figo esattamente figlio tolto mi sto qua
da tutti malissimo perché sono in piedi
e vabbè comunque
ok era che abbiamo finito il tour
dall'altro i capelli miei stanno appunto
a random pietà hanno detto che è stato
obama il fratello non sapevo neanche io
adesso c'è fa vj ok a carica siamo fuori
per la mente stiamo andando al agli
studi della fox che questo è il nostro
hotel stiamo andando con la comitiva the
youtuber sarà una figata pazzesca ed
escono idea comunque sarà una cosa epica
e sono tutti con la videocamera d'altro
c'è chi ha videocamere cioè chi ha delle
navi da crociera tipo questo poi ci sono
anch'io che togo da solo bufale vera lo
giuro non ho mai visto una cosa così
ma lei non è una youtuber freddo eccoli
lui e un giapponese state ci facciamo
mancare
io io porto fortuna io molto fortuna i
giapponesi dopo del dopodomani il
giappone ci dichiara guerra ed è finita
la pacchia
stiamo entrando in carcere dimmi
prepotenti a questa proprietà è chiusa
al pubblico e noi ci stiamo a gravare
forti sono tipo le sfere quelle che
usano nel film per uccidere le persone
tipo fanno
e adesso ci prova anche una vita che non
funziona prova cipro non funziona un
cazzo devo affinare la tecnica però a
parte i coltellazzi questi sono ragazzi
gli artigli di wolverine che li causato
nel film di tutti i film e mi hanno
detto tra l'altro che sono affilati c'è
tipo sono proprio nel senso potresti
ammazzare una persona vera me non ho
capito bene perché siamo fatti così
perché c'è il rischio di ammazzare
veramente persone trovate a 0 questa
questi sono gli artigli di wolverine
quelli veri del film cioè sono fatti
sono questi
e devo dire che sono leggermente pesanti
ma sii più del naso e se libro del naso
sono problemi anche se si gratta la
schiena e la carta igienica ci hai
pensato un casino la [ __ ] e questa
ragazzi queste tecnologie guardate ora
glielo va ovviamente a natale lo potete
mettere fuori di casa proprio fa così
con la musichetta di buon natale
fantastico ho fatto vedere prima il
casco per evitare che si possa entrare
nella mente delle persone sei bellissimo
adesso posso andare in modo da non
capisco sono tutti inglesi
volevo pagare anche ai ragazzi siamo
nella parte tipo di new york quella dei
set praticamente qua fanno film su film
sul film fanno tutta questa è una zona
proprio fatto apposta per per i film non
capisco che ci sia gente in bici non ho
idea comunque va bene non proprio ben
presente quali film han fatto di sta
roba successo su questo set però è una
figata pace sono tutti i finti si codice
è pazzesco giusto per capire che cazzo
non mi mi fa strano perché è stato
versato tipo là sopra da così così mai
finto c'è non è vinto tutto un set
quindi mi fa veramente veramente strano
sono le sei del mattino anzi esse e
mezzo sarà il fuso orario non so che
cazzo è praticamente qui in america mi
sveglio la mattina presto quando è
ancora buio non so se si vede pochissimo
però al di là un po di luce uscita ma
c'è quando mi sono svegliato era
completamente buio comunque comprato un
board
riempito di souvenir e queste così ho
preso questa che sarebbe la scritta di
hollywood fatta prefigga preso anche
tipo la maglietta dell'hard rock quella
di hollywood la scritta o cristo nato
per trovarla con la scritta di hollywood
perché non potevo la scritta los angeles
poi trovato questo che mi sembra
abbastanza carino che il l'oscar di
hollywood che sta con meno vento sulla
mensola in camera nell'angolo nerd alla
fox ho preso la maglietta più bella che
abbia mai visto in vita mia te che
questa allucinata noi o io questa come
l'ho vista ho detto basta ne voglio 50
emerso ragazzi come souvenir e per i
miei amici ho preso questo
che sarebbe una calamita da tre dollari
e 50 che si mette sul frigo devo dire
ragazzi che comunque a parte tutto è
stata una figata pazzesca cioè non non
pensavo veramente fosse così figo tratto
qua fanno dei buffer alla nutella per
colazione che sono grossi così
probabilmente vomiterà dopo ma non
importa andare a fare colazione ragazzo
troppa fame questo ragazzi è stato la
mia esperienza los angeles è stato la
mente fantastico non lo rifarei
veramente un milione di volte ma fatto
ragazzi video del ritorno in aereo
perché ero stanco morto cioè tipo vedete
camminavo tipo zombie
ecco quindi no non mi è sembrato giusto
filmarmi in quelle condizioni comunque è
stato meraviglioso l'aereo è caduto però
poi abbiamo notato ci sono salvati
quindi state tranquilli da oggi ragazzi
si parte con i video quindi non vi
preoccupate spero che video vi sia
piaciuto anche se non ho mai fatto video
di questo gene quindi spero vi sia
piaciuto ugualmente quindi ragazzi se il
video mi è piaciuto ma sento lasciato
commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come noi mito tratta
descrizione se non saresti discreti noi
ci mettiamo il prossimo video belle
ragazze